good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-575 object class
Keter special containment procedures any
and all instances of scp-559 and
contained with protocol al 907 t7c
advanced lighting and emergency
containment strategies handbook and
transported to secure containment should
an instance of scp-575 exceed a safely
containable size protocol al 9o 77 b is
to be used to divide an isolate a CP 575
into smaller instances containment units
are to be made of two airtight rooms
each sealed by airlocks the outer room
containment a is to remain lit at all
times with no less than two backup
generators on standby light fixtures are
to be checked weekly and any blackouts
in containment a will result in
immediate lockdown until total
illumination is restored the inner
containment unit containment B is to be
coated in a layer of pure calcium both
inside and out personnel entering
containment B are to be fitted with LED
embedded clothing and equipped with
portable floodlights in case of
emergency interaction with scp-575
should be limited to sample collection
and observation any samples obtained
from a CP 575 must be treated in the
same manner as the original source and
all test areas must have calcium lining
and emergency illumination procedures
similar to those outlined here any and
all civilian deaths resulting from
scp-575 are to be attributed to wild
animal attack or scavenger predation of
an already deceased subject should
deeper scrutiny be applied attacks are
to be blamed on a serial killer or
satanic cult and any additional
information is sealed due to ongoing
investigation
description scp-575 appears to be an
unknown form of matter taking the form
of a series of amorphous black shapes
and structures
scp-575 is difficult to observe as it
immediately dissipates when exposed to
light current testing has been unable to
identify of scp-575 is organic or
inorganic despite the lack of any
visible nervous systems or observable
organic components scp-575 displays
behavior consistent with an active
consciousness as CP 575 initially
manifests in total darkness how this
occurs is unknown however tests have
shown a variable mass of scp-575 forming
wimple variable along with the time
frame scp-575 is capable of floating and
can alter its density allowing it to
pass through very small openings
scp-575 prefers very dark isolated
locations in which to settle after its
initial formation and will remain there
until it reaches critical mass at
scp-575 grows with the absorption of
biological material
scp-575 will attack living things by
solidifying portions of itself and using
these appendages to bludgeon cut and
crush subjects the tracking and
selection methods used by scp-575 are
currently not understood upon disabling
a subject scp-575 will forcibly tear and
crush tissue within the main mass until
it is absorbed
scp-575 is unable to interact with
objects rich in calcium however and
nesting areas for scp-575 can be
identified by the large amounts of bones
teeth and calcified dust around them
scp-575 is capable of manifesting in any
areas of total darkness this appears to
be a form of spontaneous generation and
can form in any suitably dark location
after
scp-575 was initially recovered under
the home of mr. and his family when
initial contact was made as CP 575 had
digested the household and had partially
consumed a neighbor one age since this
initial contact instances of scp-575
have been recovered most of which have
been in residential homes or large
buildings such as factories or schools
the cause for this preference is unknown
however it has been suggested that the
building behaviors of man simply provide
more suitable nesting areas or that
scp-575 somehow needs a nearby human
presence both theories are under
investigation if you needed any other
reasons to be scared of the dark now you
have them thanks SCP foundation all
right that about does it for today thank
you all for listening and you were all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to slump god Justin day John Porter
fluffy Pierce M Hamlin white crew beware
600 my archive curator neck tie verbal
Kody tench cheese whip dips McGee and
oblong dish boy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]